it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson
might be setting the bar for
co-parenting like a boss but that
doesn't mean their relationship is back
on a source tells ET that despite
reports the exes are not officially back
together
another source adds that Khloe is being
cautious with Tristan quote at the end
of the day Khloe wants her daughter true
to have both her parents around as much
as possible and if they can make it work
she wants to try Khloe has gone through
a lot and has reiterated that to Tristan
who insists he has changed and despite
everything they've been through e t--'s
source says they are on good terms and
adds that the same is true of Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott so I'm excited
about it and Kourtney Kardashian and her
ex Scott Disick it was definitely a
process quote they're all family
everyone gets along and everyone has the
kids best interests in mind I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style we come from a family where we
believe in that and you shared children
with people and that's how it should be
and love is love Kylie and Travis share
a two-year-old daughter stormy while
Kourt and Scott are Co parents to three
kiddos ten-year-old Mason seven-year-old
daughter Penelope and five-year-old son
Raine
I think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day I mean you just want to be happy
you want to be content you want to be
comfortable life is a challenge and if
you work at what you want you can get it
but it takes hard work simple as that
you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and that's a be
a separate source previously told ET
that Khloe and Tristan have been
isolating together and have really
enjoyed their time with daughter true
this alone time has really allowed them
to reconnect without outside influences
I love it romance rumors have been
swirling around the two since Khloe's
36th birthday bash where Tristan was in
attendance with family and friends the
NBA star shared this adorable family pic
on Instagram over the weekend alongside
a sweet bday message for Coco quote I
thank God for the beautiful and loving
woman you are to everyone especially our
daughter true you deserve the world Coco
true and I love you mama you're crying
anyway Chloe and Tristan split in
February 2019
candle with kylie jenner's former bestie
jordan woods you know things happen and
of course I'm sorry and apologetic but
they've since built a positive
co-parenting relationship for true I'm
just super happy and content and I'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and soul and true
[Music]